on va l'écouter
du gouvernement
pas du tout l'application de l'article
44-3 du vote unique c'est la conséquence
de l'application de la constitution de
la 5ème République et il a sans doute
oublié que à l'époque la gauche sous
François Hollande dans son quinquennat
ici au Sénat avait utilisé à 9 reprises
ce vote bloqué nous on veut aller au
fond et on va aller au bout pour voter
et la gauche est mauvaise expérience
perdant puisque ils sentent bien qu'ils
sont en minorité évidemment sur ce texte
donc ils veulent à tout prix nous
empêcher empêcher la majorité de voter
ça c'est pas la démocratie ça on peut
pas tolérer avec une obstruction que je
n'ai jamais vu depuis 20 ans au Sénat
ils ont créé une sorte
d'industrialisation de l'obstruction
mais on peut pas vis-à-vis d'une
majorité que nous représentons se faire
prendre en otage par une minorité ça pas
la démocratie vous voyez nous on va
aller au fond et on veut discuter vous
rendez compte je l'ai souligné 449
demandes de rapport qui ont été déposés
des amendements des amendements et à
chaque fois un amant seulement de sous
amendement c'est-à-dire que on aurait pu
ajouter 10 jours 15 jours à chaque fois
il y aurait eu la machine à sous-amander
des amendements totalement ridicules qui
ne sont pas des amendements des sous
amendements au fond c'est ça
l'obstruction bien contre l'obstruction
il y a le règlement du Sénat mais qui
n'y suffit pas il y a aussi des articles
de la Constitution on est sous la
Cinquième République passe sous la
Quatrième République ici au Sénat c'est
pas la rue qui fait la loi la loi c'est
la démocratie représentative il y a le
droit de grève on a le droit de
manifester dans le calme bien sûr
pacifiquement je le reconnais
complètement mais ici notre job c'est
pas seulement de parler à l'infini notre
job c'est de voter mais après ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée est-ce que ce
vote bloqué sa fragil la réforme sa
légitimité non on est déjà l'article 9
on a fait passer des marqueurs qui sont
pour nous très très importants et en
réalité il reste quelques articles
puisque sur les 20 articles de la
réforme la réforme tient en très
articles les derniers articles ce sont
des articles techniques que vous
retrouvez dans les lois de finances des
tableaux d'équilibre qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'essentiel le cœur de la
réforme donc je pense que on peut
continuer à aller au bout de ce texte il
le faut impérativement en discutant du
fond ça sert à rien de discuter des sous
amendements qui par dizaines par
centaines sont déposées et qui leur
vient dire on déplace d'un jour un
rapport qu'il faut déposer à tel moment
etc etc
[Musique]